I'm Vince Hurnley and I am a Scoutmaster with Troop 73 in Indianapolis, Indiana.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now it's the old Scoutmaster
Getting ready to go camping and we're on daylight savings time now, so the you know, shorter days,
but the sun is really, really bright in the winter, especially when it snows.
So in preparation I got myself some really dark goggles to wear,
But you know, to tell you the truth, I can't see myself wearing.
Thank you, Shane.
Shane Adams gave me the idea for that one,
If not exactly that one.
So let's not, let's not, blame Shane.
Okay,
Hey, this is podcast number 329..
Yeah
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Heard from Frank Rossmark, who listened to podcast 327 and said:
I really do like the picture for that podcast.
If you haven't seen the picture, you got to go back and look.
Go over to scoutmastercgcom,
Look up podcast 327..
Look at the picture.
Fred went on to say you didn't even touch on double secret probation.
Well, of course I didn't, Fred, because it's secret.
Cha
Heard from Paul Geisler, who is in the Laurel Highlands Council,
And Paul has published a survey as a part of his work for the
College of Commissioner Science.
I'm going to have a link to the survey in the podcast notes.
Go ahead and check it out,
Help, Paul.
Thanks Paul for alerting us to that.
We did have a live chat-
I think it was Wednesday this past week
And I can't say welcome to anybody new because nobody new
showed up- but the good old frequent flyers were there
And we discussed nothing important at all-
Not that I can recall at least.
But we'll solve that.
We'll discuss many important things on the podcast.
I want to pause before I go any further, though, to thank all the
folks who are scoutmastercgcom backers-
And I want to personally thank Shane Adams and Jim Gilligy who
have become backers since last week's podcast-
And I want to thank all the folks who have subscribed via
Patreon.
If you'd like to become a backer or join our Patreon
subscribers, visit scoutmastercgcom.
You'll find links to follow at the top right of any
page,
And you'll also find links on how to make that happen in
this episode's podcast notes.
Got a couple of email questions to answer this week,
So let's get started, shall we?
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Find me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
So neither of these emails are going to have any names
or anything associated with them.
Sensitive subjects again, or people just requested not to
have their name mentioned on the podcast
Email number one says my son joined a great troop
two years ago from Weeblows
And I became the membership chair.
Our scout master is a good guy but not a good
listener.
When you try to talk to him he talks over you
and he never really hears what you're saying and
has said himself that he does not delegate well.
The result of this is that camping trips may get
planned halfway but don't always happen.
Fellow scouters are frustrated trying to help
out,
So this results in fewer stepping up to help out,
increasing the load on an already overloaded
scout master.
Programs starting to fray around the edges were
a good size troop with as many as 70 scouts,
But I worry the frustration is building and
people will start leaving.
I asked my son if he wanted to look around and,
as you may have already guessed, he said
no, he likes this troop,
But that doesn't mean I'm not worried.
He's a patrol leader.
He sends an email once a week, but what kind
of training is he getting?
I'm sure he should be getting more than that,
And I sure that he probably is,
And I want my son to be happy, but I also
want him to benefit from the entire program
too, and seeing that the program in this
troop is a little troubled, I'm wondering
what to do.
Can you give me any advice on this situation?
Yeah, this kind of situation is going to
need some leadership from the committee chair
and the committee is going to need to back
him up.
I would say probably the first step is looking
at the way things are done.
If you have a new scout master replacing
a long-serving scout master, there's
almost certainly going to be problems
because the long-term scout master
probably did a lot more than they really
should have and the committee
kind of has little idea of exactly
what's going on. or maybe
personnel on the committee changed,
maybe have a new committee chair with
an old scout master who doesn't really
know what to do.
But look, this is a pretty typical
problem because the kind of person
who's going to step up
and be a scout master is going to be the
kind of person who feels
very responsible and probably somewhat
controlling over exactly
how and what should happen, and they're
not likely to hand off
responsibility or authority to other
people. I mean, I've seen that happen
many, many times.
So there has to be some collaboration
between the committee chair,
the members of the committee, the scout master
and the other scouters involved.
They have to come up with a plan,
and that a plan involves first
assessing what's going on and
what's not getting done and what needs
to happen. and if nobody's
capable or unwilling to do things
like that, things aren't going to get
any better and you probably lose some
scouts. and then everybody wakes up
and you go back and you do that process.
But as soon as the red flags start
going up, as soon as people get concerned
about this sort of thing, you
really need to sit down and do
an evaluation of exactly where you are
and where you're headed and how things are going to work.
This is not something
that we often do or we're very good at,
mostly because the demands on your time
as a volunteer you don't have time
to step back and take a look. But
it's something that's really important to do
and it's a good process
to go through on an annual basis.
I mean, when's the last time anybody asked
the committee chair or the scout master,
how long they were going to be around,
What their plan was for the next three or four years.
You know, those are the kind of questions
that don't often get asked
but that need to be The troops a little
dysfunctional, the programs
fraying around the edges, like you say. but
consider this: that 90% of the troops
I communicate with have one or more
dysfunctions of some kind. I mean
we only have to look at our own families
to understand that everybody
is managing some sort of
dysfunction, major or minor. Now
it's safe to say that any scout
in any one of those troops
are probably not being harmed
by participating. They're happy,
they're with their friends, they're having a good
time, they're learning some things along the way,
but they're also reaching
the aim, which is they're developing
character, they're developing as a human being,
Even if the program isn't
hitting on all eight cylinders every
single time. like I say,
scouts aren't being harmed,
things are going along. are they getting
100%?
Well, you know how important is that
So far as the scout is concerned,
I doubt they feel like they're missing out
and there is a lot of pressure on
parents to kind of commodify
our children's experiences in attempt
to upgrade right,
I mean, if they're not going to the absolute
best school, maybe we should find the absolute
best school. If they're not in the absolute
best group, maybe we should find that
You know what kind of soccer team
should they be on? I mean, there's a lot of
pressure and while we're involved
in that kind of worrying, we're
actually missing out on what's happening
in their lives. Could you find a better
troop team,
teacher, coach, scout, master,
pastor, school, church,
house to live in,
town to live in, or set of parents
even? Well, of course, you could,
theoretically. While we're concerned
with all this optimization,
our children are living their lives
and being happy and growing
right, And so let's not miss that.
and it's not about giving up
and accepting second or third best.
I don't
think that way. I think it's more about
growing where you're planted. We can't
optimize absolutely everything about our
lives or our children's lives,
and making the best of where we are
and who we are
is a pretty important life skill, right?
So, that being said,
I do often counsel people who are
unhappy to look for another troop, and some
do. but in this case
you've asked your son. he seems to be
fine. Your experience
and his experience of scouting are two
completely different things. If he's
unhappy or uncomfortable with his troop,
then it's time to look elsewhere.
If he's happy, I mean,
you can do what you can to help the
committee, but you can also
do just so much,
and then we need to, like,
do the serenity thing right. There are
things I can control, there's things I
can't, but I can
do what I can do to help make this
organization better. In the meantime,
my son is a scout and he's having a great
time. Email number 2:
Oh, this is the Marripadge
one. Okay, well, this gets into
what could be
a little dangerous territory. but-
and this is the way the email begins-
I volunteered to be a Marripadge
counselor for a number of Marripadges.
I have not been able to find or
attend any formal Marripadge counselor
training sessions, but I find
I have two general questions.
Question number 1:
What's the correct or the best way
to handle requirements in a group situation?
Some requirements look
kind of like they're supposed to be done
individually and some look like they could
be handled by a group. Question number 2
is: how much guidance or
direction can a counselor provide?
Do the scouts need to do all the research
by themselves or can I provide
all of the information? Two very general,
very innocent questions,
but ones that are perennial. I
get these kind of questions all the time
when it comes to Marripadges and
Marripadge counseling. So let's deal
with number 1. The best
way to handle requirements in a group situation.
Well, for that I'm going to
send you to the Guide to Advancement
and the section about Marripadges,
and there is a specific section
about groups and if you want the number
of the section, it's 7.0,
.3.2 and
it's titled Group
Instruction. How about that?
I'm going to read from that section:
It is acceptable,
and sometimes desirable for Marripadges
to be taught in group settings.
So we know that, yes,
you can use group settings
to counsel Marripadges.
You read on a little bit further. it says:
because of the
importance of individual
attention and
personal learning in the Marripadges program,
group instruction should be
focused on those scenarios
where the benefits are compelling.
There must be attention to each
individual's projects
and his fulfillment of all requirements.
We must know that
every scout actually and personally
completed them, Unquote.
Okay, so, groups are good, but
remember, use the group setting
only where it makes the most sense.
So if you're going to
have a group and getting
them all together and explaining something all at once,
well, that makes sense. Let's go back to
what the guide to advancement has to say.
Quote: if, for example,
a requirement uses words like
show, demonstrate or
discuss, then every scout
must do that. It is
unacceptable to award badges
on the basis of sitting in classrooms
watching demonstrations
or remaining silent during discussions.
Okay, so that
makes sense, right? So groups,
yes, you can use groups.
only use the group setting where the benefits are compelling.
and then remember that
everybody has to do the active
things like show, demonstrate
or discuss. They can't just
be part of a group where
a percentage of people are showing
or demonstrating or discussing.
Finally, the guide to advancement says this:
there must be attention to
each individual's project
and his fulfillment of all requirements.
We must know that every scout
actually and personally completed them
Unquote. Okay, so there's
the advice from the guide to advancement.
So, while there's a lot of instruction
that could be done on a group basis,
the evaluation has to be done
on an individual basis. I don't
counsel merit badges anymore- I used
to- and I recommend against
group instruction if at all possible.
and your second question about
how much should I share with the scouts, Should I get them
to research things or something like that.
Well, your best guide as to how you should
handle that sort of thing
is in the requirements themselves.
Take them literally. If the requirement says
you should go and look this up,
the scout should go and look it up.
If it says, ask your counselor
about, that's fine.
The idea of merit badges
is not limited to the completion
of the requirements as a
benefit for the scout. The actions
that they have to take
to complete the requirements are also
a benefit to them. And what I mean
by that? if it says,
talk to somebody in such and such an occupation
about what they do, Well,
the counselor might be the person in that
occupation or
the scout might have to find somebody.
and that is a pretty big life lesson
right there, For a scout
to have to find somebody, contact
another adult whom they don't know
and be able to question them
and be able to walk away with some kind of understanding.
I think that's a good idea,
Of course, all the time
keeping the matrix
of our youth protection practices
in mind. So
you think you know everything. Why don't you
just tell us
What? Oh, so you don't
have any opinion about it at all? right,
You, really? you
don't want me to start on that, do you?
I don't know everything. All I have is
a microphone. okay, I get to
talk into it and people listen to it.
You're just going to read off of what you wrote
to get ready for the podcast. That's it, huh,
Nothing else. Oh, I definitely
have some opinions.
Wait, have we met?
It's
only going to royal the waters
and I people don't want to hear all
that. I don't know about that. You haven't
been on the soapbox for a while. Get out the soapbox.
Nobody wants me to climb up on a soapbox
and tell them what I think about merit badges.
Yeah, really Go ahead. Why not?
All right,
All right, It's your fault.
You asked. So here I'm
going to go. I don't like
merit badges.
I like the idea
of merit badges, but I here.
look, let's start with this.
Why do we have
merit badges?
You ever think about that? I mean,
they're there and they're
a hollow tradition and they're
part of the culture and all that.
but do you ever have to
stop and think: why are we doing this?
I think it's important to
ask those questions personally.
So who invented them?
Let's go back and look at what
Baden Powell had to say.
He wrote a book called AIDS to Scout
Mastership. You can find the whole thing
on my website at
scoutmastercgcom. Look in the library
link in the menu. You'll find AIDS to
Scout Mastership. It should be required
reading for every scouter. All right, So this is
what Baden Powell had to say. He said:
proficiency badges- that's what they
called merit badges at the time- are
established with a view to developing in
each lad the taste for hobbies
which may ultimately give him a career
and not leave him hopeless
and helpless on going out into the world.
So Baden Powell
thought that these proficiency badges would
be a lot of fun and you'd get
exposed to different hobbies or handicrafts,
and it may.
it doesn't have to, but
it would expose you to the world
of work and you may find your career
in having done that.
That's really great and that's
one of the intentions. but it's only one
of them, because he goes on to say this:
the badges are merely
intended as an encouragement to
a boy to take up a hobby
or an occupation or make some sort of progress
in it. They are assigned
to an outsider that he has done
so. They are not
intended to signify that he
is a master in the craft that
he has tested in. Okay,
So this is a pretty casual
setup. This is so
that you can investigate these different things-
not master them,
you know, but
just investigate them and to have
fun doing it right,
I mean it makes sense.
so let's go on
and keep reading what Baden Powell had to say.
he says: if we at once
make scouting into a formal scheme
of serious instruction
inefficiency, we miss the whole
point of value of scout training
and we trench the work of schools
without the trained experts for carrying
it out. We want to get
all our boys along through
cheery self-development from within,
not through the imposition
of formal instruction from without.
ah, now we see
the contrast between how
maripages were intended by the person
who invented them and what we do
today, because we have made
them into a formal scheme
of serious instruction inefficiency
and we are trenching the work
of schools without the trained experts
for carrying it out. and we
kind of ignored the point of getting
all of our boys along through
cheery self-development from within
by imposing formal
instruction on them from without.
okay, that's a problem,
but there's another reason
that we have maripages.
the object of the badge system in
scouting, Baden Powell says,
is also to give the scout master
an instrument by which he can
stimulate keenness on the part
of every and any boy
to take up hobbies that can be helpful
in forming his character or developing
his skill. oh okay,
so there's more benefit to it
than just finding
out about the world. it's also
a good way for a
scouter to encourage
scouts to spread their wings a little
bit and to challenge
some things and to develop
their character and skill.
Baden Powell goes on to say:
it is an instrument which,
if applied with understanding
and sympathy,
is designed to give hope and ambition
to even the dullest and most
backward who would otherwise
be quickly at distance and
so rendered hopeless in the race
of life. it is for this reason
that the standard of proficiency
is purposefully left
undefined.
oh wait, a minute, now let's unpack that.
it is for this reason.
alright, what reason?
so that everybody can give this a
shot, challenge something and be
successful at it. yes,
Baden Powell 100 years ago
was saying: this is an instance
where everybody gets to win,
no matter how well they do.
we're judging them not against
some standard we've
defined, but against their
own personal effort. he goes on
to explain this even more
by saying: our standard for bad
earning is not the attainment
of a certain
quality of knowledge or skill,
but the amount of effort
the boy has put into
acquiring such knowledge
or skill. this brings the most hopeless
case on a footing of equal
possibility with his more
brilliant or better off brother.
wow, that's kind of interesting, isn't it?
it's not about the attainment
of a certain level or quality
of knowledge or skill,
but the amount of effort put into
acquiring the knowledge
and skill, and it's something
that boys get to do
and succeed in as
a model for the other challenges
that they're going to meet in life.
Ben Powell says a boy
in whom the inferiority
complex has been born through many
failures can have his
first win or two made
easy for him
so that he is led
to intensify his efforts.
if he is a trier, no matter how clumsy
his examiner,
can accord him his badge,
and this generally inspires
the boy to go on trying
till he wins further badges
and becomes normally capable.
okay, so
let's think about this for a moment.
Ben Powell said
he wanted these badges
to be a gateway into
the world of work in one way,
that he wanted them not to have
a certain standard of proficiency
and that they had other ancillary
benefits for scouts, because,
rather than having one set
standard for proficiency,
there is an instrument, a tool
in this badge system
that can be used to encourage
taking on challenges
and improving your idea
of yourself. the way we evaluate
how well you've done
is not, according to the other guy,
your achievement against some set standard,
but the effort that you've
put into it.
Ben Powell says some are inclined to insist
that their scouts should be first rate
before they can get a badge,
which is very right in theory.
you do get a few scouts pretty proficient
in this way, but our object is to get
all of our scouts interested
and active at the same time.
he goes on to say:
I do not recommend the other extreme,
namely that of almost giving away
the badges on very slight knowledge
of the subjects.
it is a matter where examiners should use
their sense and discretion,
keeping the main aim in view.
use your sense and discretion
and keep the main aim in view.
how about working with each scout
on an individual basis,
tailoring the experience
so that he gets the most out of it?
keeping the main aim in view,
which is what
the development of character
goes on to talk about the danger of badge hunting,
in other words, just earning
badges for the sake of earning badges
and badge earning
right. so
the idea of scouting is not that
it's all about earning badges
and that you should be on this
continuous badge hunt.
no, it's about earning badges
as a result of the things that you do naturally
as a scout, while you enjoy the outdoors
with your fellow scouts.
it's all very simple, isn't it
okay? so that's what
Baden Powell had to say
about why we have
merit badges.
what I have to say
here's what you can do.
you can choose to keep on listening to this-
I'm standing solidly on my soapbox
and I'm preaching about this-
or you can just skip to the closing.
you might want to just skip to the closing.
here's the problem.
there's actually little hope
of achieving
the aims that Baden Powell
laid out
when he started the whole thing
and what we have now,
which I call the merit badge
industrial complex.
the merit badge industrial complex
that we've created-
has three major problems.
we think the idea
of merit badges is to get as many scouts
merit badges in the shortest time possible.
now, nobody will tell you
that that's what they're trying to do,
but for the most part, that's how we've engineered
the system. everybody should get
as many badges as they possibly can,
and you should get them all the time,
and we should focus huge
blocks of the effort that we spend in the program
on getting merit badges.
from what I observed personally
and what people tell me, I think
that's a reasonable statement
and that's how we've engineered the system.
it ought to be telling that we call
the people who facilitate scouts
getting merit badges a counselor
rather than a teacher.
I mean, each merit badge should be
an individual quest,
not a group exercise.
each person working with a scout on a merit badge
should be counseling them,
helping them along the way,
working with them on an individual basis,
not teaching big groups of scouts
and not having tests and examinations
at the end of things
to evaluate everybody based on a mean.
no,
it should be very highly individualized
if we want to get it the way Baden Powell intended it.
but that's really difficult to do
because the requirements for merit badges
have proliferated
and they've become incredibly restrictive
about the ability of a counselor
to shape the experience for an individual scout.
there's really no joint
adventure in following a set of
10 or 20 requirements that are written
more like an engineering spec
right than a doorway
to exploring interesting subjects.
I mean
the way that the badges are written,
the way the requirements are written
seems like it's intentional
to take all the fun out of it.
you know,
I mean, it's so closely defined
exactly what you have to do
that you have to grab the merit badge book
and you have to look at the merit badge book
and say this is exactly what you should do-
and here's exactly the words that you should say-
to fulfill the requirement of these badges.
that's why I kind of look at it
as an assembling line,
as kind of merit badge industrial complex,
right.
the other problem is we require specific
badges for ranks
and we eliminate what Baden Powell was thinking,
and that is merely
intending them as an encouragement,
and we make them into a set of standards
that must be adhered to
in the purposeful attempt
to standardize the achievements
of all of our scouts.
why do we need that?
I don't think we need that.
I don't think that helps us achieve our aim.
and while I'm on the soapbox,
I'll note, as I have many times,
perhaps not quite so vocally:
the whole merit badge industrial complex
has totally ruined the summer camp
experience and I think it's been that way
for quite a long time.
as a past camp director and somebody who's been involved
for 20 or 30 years
in camp programs and working with counselors
at camp. I've worked with
hundreds and hundreds of staff members.
I've worked with thousands
of scouts and probably
tens of thousands of scouts,
and you are helpless
to try and change anything about this,
because there's one reason that scouts go to camp
and one reason that
scouts take them and that is to get
as many merit badges as possible.
and I know people will say, oh no, no, no,
that's not the way that we do things.
I'm telling you in general.
I don't think you can argue with that conclusion.
if there are more merit badges at camp A,
then there are. at camp B,
scouts are going to go to camp A.
if scouts can come home
with more merit badges at camp A,
then they can. at camp B,
scouts are going to go to camp A.
now I won't say that this is absolutely
everyone. of course it isn't,
because I've talked to some of you
and corresponded with some of you
who don't like this whole merit badge
summer camp thing any more than I do.
but there's tremendous pressure
on scouts. you know our hollow tradition:
we go to summer camp
and knock off three to five merit badges
and you spend all your time sitting on your butt
in an air-conditioned lodge somewhere,
just like you did at school all year,
and it just makes me absolutely
crazy. you're at
summer camp. what are all
the marvelous things that you can do here
that you can do nowhere else?
you know? certainly not sitting in a classroom
somewhere. but now I'm beginning to
rant, so I will
back off a little bit
and stop ranting. you
ask: do I have an answer for all this?
I do.
I found what looks to me like
a really good way to handle things,
and I only mention it here because it's
soapbox time, not because I think we should
start a movement that goes out and makes this change,
because
I don't think this change will ever happen,
because it would be a massive sea change
in our organization.
but I'll tell you this:
some years ago the World Organization
of the Scouting Movement published a document
called Renewed Approach to Program.
if you go online
you can probably find it.
it's called the RAP-
Renewed Approach to Program-
and Scouts Ireland and Scouts Canada
and, to my understanding, Scouts Australia-
are kind of spearheading
program changes
driven by that document,
and I think that's a lot of the things that they're doing
are brilliant,
and I think Scouts Ireland is probably the farthest ahead
of any Scouting organization
in the WOSM
implementing the ideas in that RAP program,
and I could go on to explain it.
but look, they took all the
important everyday Scouts
skills right, all the important things that Scouts
do. they put those
in groups of adventure skills
and each one of the groups
has- oh I don't know- a dozen to
20 different levels
in that skill that you can pursue as a
Scout based on your interest.
if they haven't eliminated
ranks, they've greatly
reduced emphasis on them,
while they have highlighted the idea
that Scouts should learn,
practice
and have fun with
these adventure skills.
and they have something called special
interest badges. I don't think any.
I don't think they ever called them merit badges,
frankly, in Ireland,
but they have basically what we would call a merit
badge to that is called a special
interest badge and there are five
broad areas defined
and you as a Scout
can do up to three special
interest badges in each one of those
five areas in a given age group
and Scouts. so when you're a Cub Scout
you can do up to 15
special interest badges,
three from each of the five groups,
when you're a Scout, when you're a Venturer,
when you're a Rover, etc.
so the special interest badges
encourages you to diversify because
there are five different interest groups
so you can't spend all your time
in just one interest group.
and then the requirements for the special interest
badges. I know that you're curious
about how they do requirements for all these special
interest badges. well, I'll tell you.
it's one sheet of paper
that says: you choose an area of
interest, you find somebody who's
willing to counsel you in that area of interest
and then you and the counselor
write up the requirements
that you're going to do to get that badge.
and I think that is much
more in the spirit of what
Baden Powell was trying to achieve
when he established proficiency badges.
then we are experiencing with
the Merit Badge industrial complex.
let me get down off of my
soapbox. please
definitely get in touch
and let me know what you think.
if you think I'm a nutcase,
that's fine, because you're not
alone. if you think that
some of this sounded reasonable,
that's fine. I'm not going to lead
any giant revolution on this.
what I'm interested in is starting
to ask questions
and starting to think about exactly
how we're doing things and asking
ourselves: you know,
maybe a system that has accreted
over the past many, many decades
bears some examining
and some changing. that's what I suggest.
I think that would be a good
starting point, don't you,
hey, listen? if you have a question
or a comment- and I'm going to get a lot
of comments this week, I imagine
you can get in touch with me. it's
pretty easy to do and I'm going to tell you
how to do that in just a moment.
well, thank you for listening to this
329th edition of the scout master
podcast. it's very easy
to keep in touch. start by going to
scoutmastercgcom.
there's over 1600 articles
and over 300 editions of the
podcast. there. there's plenty of stuff
to look at and while you're there,
you can subscribe to receive updates
by email. you can also keep track
of what we're up to in the vast
panorama of social media.
there's 15,000 plus folks
who like scoutmaster blog on
facebook, where you're much more than
just a face in the crowd.
oh, we've got a chorus of tweeters on twitter
who type tremendously thoughtful
tweets and we pin
pultritudinous pictures, proffered publicly,
with a parcel of prolific pinners. on pinterest,
you can watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube. but
oh my, you say I can't face
facebook and twitter makes me better. I don't
have any interest in pinterest
and I do not put the? u in youtube,
sir, and to that I answer:
it's okay, bunkie,
just zoom in to the late 1990s
and fire off a good old fashioned
email. dust off that desktop
system that's been sitting in the corner
unused all these years.
log on to your AOL account
and you can get in touch with me,
Clark Green, at Clark,
at scoutmastercgcom
C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmaster
c-g
com,
and, if all else fails, if you get on the
roof of your camp headquarters building,
you'll find a big spotlight that projects
a special signal up against the clouds.
switch it on for a few minutes
at night and I'll make sure to be in touch
by now. it should be abundantly clear that
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster
podcast are not official
publications of anyone
other than myself. I am neither
endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts
of America or any other scouting organization
for that matter. no, no, no,
it is just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here he is
our founder, sir Robert
Baden Powell. sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
oh, I thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.